次の動画のテーマは、研究倫理です。大学院生の皆さんはおそらくですね、研究倫理の講習を受けたり、内容について学んだりということもあるかと思います。
復習になる部分も多いかと思いますが、まずはちょっと外観していただければというふうに思います。
研究倫理の話がですね、非常に取り出されたのは、多分スタップ細胞の時とかなんですかね。
あの時ぐらいに僕は学生というか、大学院生だったと思うんですけど、何年前ですっけ、ちょっともう記憶がないですね。
2014年か、ということは僕は右さんか何かだったら、学部の単元だったわけですね。
非常にあの時に問題になってですね、そこから先に倫理面、しっかり教育していこうね、みたいなところが出てきたわけでございます。
まず、なぜ倫理が重要かということを、皆さんは理解していく必要があると思うんですね。
端的に言えば、皆さんのほとんどは良い論文を書いて、それで卒業したり、あるいはですね、良い研究者になったりということを目指すと思うんですけども、
その中で倫理、ほとんどの人は守れると思いますが、重要なことは、科学は信頼を基盤に成り立っているということを理解していくことなんですね。
お互いのデータについてですね、十分に理解していて、分かっているということも必要でしょうし、
あるいはですね、科学研究によって得られた結果は、政治正しいものだというふうにみんな思うわけです。
巨人の方に乗るなんて表現もあったりしますよね。
つまり、正しいというデータを積み上げていくことによって、きちんと科学技術のですね、体系が出来上がっているわけです。
そうした体系の中にですね、信頼を失われたり、薄いデータがどんどん投げ込まれたりすると、
科学そのものを予定立つ基盤が崩れることになって、つまりは何を信じていいのか分からないということになるわけです。
日本学習振興会はですね、こういうふうに、科学の健全な発展のためにという名前で、倫理講習の教材を出しています。
こういうのですね。
これ無料で落とせますので、よかったらこれ読んでみると良いと思います。
科学者自らは誠実な研究のあるべき姿を考え行動し、さらに次世代を担う更新を育てることによって、
科学を健全に発展することができる、そういうふうに目的が書かれているわけでございます。
今、2015年の第1番というよりもですね、もっと先のですね、第2番が出ているところでございます。
そうしたですね、倫理を考えていく前にですね、
まずは大学の中でのインテグリティ、政治性についてちょっと議論させてください。
例えば、アカデミックインテグリティってどういうところであるかといったらですね、
チーティングしない、つまりカンニングしないだとか、
レポートもちゃんと自分の頭で考えるとかですね、
言われたこともオール的な話があるんですけども、
その中にですね、ファンダメンタルバリューオブアカデミックインテグリティというところで、
こういうふうな財団さんがあってですね、
1990年ぐらいから活躍されているんですかね、
どんな内容があるのみたいなことを国際的にまとめているところがあります。
その目次を見ると、第3波の中で必要なものが出てきていて、
この6つのバリューがアカデミックインテグリティにあるんだよということが書かれていたりします。
まさに正直、つまり、研究上はですね、
自分に都合が悪いデータなんて山本出てくるので、
そういうふうなことも隠さないよとか、
あるいはですね、手順を開始し検証できるとかですね、
貢献を正しく配分できる、
引用で天神に謝意を示すとか、
道具をせずに引き受けるということもあります。
それからですね、最初に近いところがありますけど、
声を上げて、誤りを垂らしましょうね、みたいなことがあったりします。
この6つの価値というのはですね、
別にAIがあるからこの価値があるわけじゃなくて、
それとは全く無関係に存在するわけですね。
これが土台を支えているわけです。
この土台に対して、
AIを誤った使い方をすると、
その土台をですね、切り崩しちゃうから、
大変だよって言われているわけでございます。
研究倫理の中ではですね、
このアカデミックインテグリティをさらに
先に伸ばしていたものだと思いますが、
もともとはですね、
プレベンティブエスティックスということで、
必要ならないことを守るということですね、
不正や被害についての、
その記述とですね、
回避のための手順だったり、
あるいは規則の遵守みたいなことがありました。
多くの人が研究倫理の時で、
最初に思いを生きているのは、
この予防な部分ですね。
一方で、昨今のですね、
研究倫理の教材を見ていると、
思考倫理、つまりこういうふうなのが、
ウェルビーイングな状態で、
良き科学者になるために、
どういうふうにすれば倫理というのが使えるのかと、
倫理という部分がですね、
どういうふうに良き科学者のために生きるのか、
ということが書かれています。
なので、ちょっと第2番はですね、
雰囲気が変わっているわけですね。
この両者とのある意味、
総合補完でして、
不正を避けるためではなくですね、
何のために結局するかということを軸に考えましょう、
ということが、
より謳われているようになってきています。
皆さんの成果、第1つよりもですね、
どのようにすれば、
この世界、
あるいは社会が良くなっていくかと、
そのために、
正しい科学を行っていくということが、
より謳われているということですね。
研究不正の中にはですね、
2つ、
何かあるわけなんですけども、
QRPというのも好ましくない研究工具と書かれていまして、
QRPというのもあるんですけど、
これもアウトですよね。
グレーと書かれていますけど、
ほぼアウトだと思います。
FFPというのは何かというとですね、
その中でもですね、
特に、
これ最悪で、
これやったらもう一発のキャリア終わるよ、
というやつでございます。
一つはですね、
通像ですね、
もう全く存在しないデータ作っちゃって、
そこから何かやっちゃうみたいな話ですね。
改ざん、
ファルシフィケーション、
これもまた大問題ですよね。
つまり、
データをですね、
都合の悪いところをどんどんどんどん書き換えちゃうということですね。
東洋というのは、
他の人のデータを元に書いちゃうということです。
これ、別に日本の国だけはこの3つをですね、
言っているわけではないんですよ。
そうじゃなくて、世界共通の研究不正として、
いろんな人が問題にしているものがこの3つでございます。
ただし、
これだけではなくてですね、
オーサーシップの問題、
つまり、
それってちゃんとその人書いてるの?
って問題だったりとか、
なんか、
聴者抜けてね?みたいなですね、
なんかこれ、
学生が一生懸命やってたのに、
学生の名前が聴者にないじゃん、
みたいな話があったりして、
そういうその、
信頼を犯すアウトゾーンみたいなのもあったりします。
あと、研究記録も不適切な感じですよね。
実験して頑張ってたのに、
それの記録が全然残ってないというのはアウトですよね。
データの保管とか保存、
あるいはデータマネジメントプランというところも、
今は非常に重要な問題として出てきています。
それから、
データの未保管だったりですね、
あるいはオープンサイエンスということで、
今や多くのジャーナルでですね、
結果につながるデータというのは公開します、
ということになっているんですけど、
それを拒否するみたいなところもアウトな範囲ですよね。
これはオサシップとも関わりますけども、
不十分な指導だったり、
学生の卓取になるような部分だったりとかですね、
成果の不誠実の発表、
つまりながら部分的にしか発表していないとかですね、
サラミ論文だったりとかもありますよね。
一つの論文で収まるものをですね、
複数出して数だけで上げちゃおうとですね、
それから申請での誇張、
ここ難しいところですよね、
今はですね、
科学的な内容をより社会に分かりやすくするためについて、
プレスリースにというのが打つじゃないですか、
その時に後方の部分とこの誇張の部分というのは、
非常に難しいところがあるのかなというふうに思います。
このようなですね、調査ではですね、
約半数、各3年でQRPを何らか経験したよと言われていますけども、
こういうのというのはですね、かなりあってはいけないんですけども、
実際には起こり得るということでございます。
それらのですね、研究の信頼を犯すようなことを皆さんには加担しないように、
あるいは危ないなと思ったら、ちゃんと勇気を持ってですね、
言うということが重要なのかなと思います。
ということで、研究倫理の部分でですね、
AIとは無関係に重要な点を説明してまいりました。
この2点ちょっと理解してほしいんですよ。
1つ目はですね、こうしたアカデミックインテグリティであったり、
あるいはこの倫理というのはですね、
AIと全く無関係に存在している価値ですよね。
科学は信頼性に足るというものは、
AIの関係性、AIが存在するかどうかに全く関係ないです。
なので、その価値というのは非常に普遍的なものとして持っていった上で、
AIを利用するかどうかを考えなければいけないということですね。
それからもう1つですね、AIがやったというのが言い訳にならないということですね。
不正かどうかというのはですね、行為そのもので判定されますと。
つまり、責任はですね、利用した研究者本人が負います。
AI自体が間違った結果を出しました。
それ、AIがやったから俺のせいじゃないよとは言えないということです。
それは全部本人が負うことになるので、その点は十分に注意しましょう。
なのでですね、守る、つまり予防的な理由だけではなくて、
そもそも研究というのは、社会を良くするために、
あるいはですね、学問の発展のためにやっているんだという、
そういうふうな大きな目的の中から考えていくと、
そういうふうな倫理的な課題というのはなくなってくると思いますので、
そういった意味でですね、なぜ倫理を考えるのかということを、
今一度皆さんの中で考えていただければと思います。
ぜひですね、こうした倫理協会もありますし、
それからですね、このようなですね、協会もあります。
今やですね、こういう英文などもAIの中で、
対話的に読むことができる時代です。
今一度ぜひ、倫理の重要性について考えてみていただければと思います。
それではこの動画を終わります。